la hibridación puede tener un gran
efecto en la estabilidad de una base
conjugada si empezamos con eta no
este carbono tiene una hibridación sp3 y
digamos que el eta no dona un protón
entonces estos electrones en rosa se
quedarán en el carbono para formar la
base conjugada aquí tenemos los
electrones en rosa y este carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 lo que significa que
los electrones en rosa ocupan un orbital
sp3 por los vídeos de hibridación
sabemos que un orbital sp3 está formado
por 25 por ciento del orbital ese y 75
por ciento del orbital p 25% del orbital
ahora vamos con el eterno o también
llamado etileno este carbono tiene una
hibridación sp2 y si el eterno con este
protón los electrones en rosa se
quedarán en el carbono que serían estos
electrones y esta es la base con jugada
del eterno entonces este carbono tiene
una hibridación sp2 así que los
electrones en rosa ocupan un orbital sp2
el orbital sp2 tiene aproximadamente un
33 por ciento del orbital ese 33% del
orbital
finalmente vamos con el acetileno este
carbono tiene una hibridación esp y el
acetileno dona éste protón estos
electrones se quedarán en el carbono
estos son los electrones en rosa y este
carbono tiene una hibridación esp así
que los electrones en rosa ocupan un
orbital esp que tiene 50% del orbital s
ahora analicemos los valores de pk
el valor de pk para este protón en el
etano es de aproximadamente 50 el valor
de pk
para
de protón en lt no es de aproximadamente
44 y el valor de pk
para este protón en el acetileno es de
aproximadamente 25 sabemos que a menor
pk a el ácido es más fuerte así que
conforme nos movemos hacia la derecha
podemos ver que el valor de pk
disminuye y por lo tanto aumenta la
acidez
aumenta la acidez así que de estos tres
el acetileno es el ácido más fuerte lo
que significa que su base conjugada es
la más estable entonces conforme nos
movemos hacia la derecha aumenta la
estabilidad aumenta la estabilidad de la
base conjugada ahora como explicamos que
aumenta la estabilidad de una base
conjugada en términos de hibridación
bueno analicemos la hibridación que ya
habíamos visto en la primera base con
jugada el par de electrones libres ocupa
un orbital con hibridación sp3 que tiene
25% del orbital ese y conforme nos
movemos hacia la derecha en las bases
conjugadas podemos ver que aumenta el
porcentaje del orbital s
de 33% a 50% entonces al movernos hacia
la derecha aumenta la estabilidad pero
también aumenta el orbital s vamos a
explicarlo pensando en orbitales esp en
promedio la densidad electrónica en un
orbital s se encuentra más cerca del
núcleo que en un orbital p
lo explicaré mejor observemos este par
de electrones que tenemos en la base
conjugada del etano si pensamos en la
distancia que hay entre los electrones y
el núcleo un orbital con hibridación sp3
tiene el menor porcentaje de orbital s
eso significa que los electrones están
más alejados del núcleo lo cual es menos
estable si nos movemos hacia la derecha
podemos ver que la distancia disminuye y
finalmente
el orbital con hibridación excepto hay
una distancia más corta entre el par de
electrones libres y el núcleo cargado
positivamente si disminuimos la
distancia entre el núcleo y los
electrones
eso significa que aumentamos la fuerza
de atracción entonces esta base
conjugada es más estable por la gran
atracción que hay entre el núcleo y los
electrones y como esta es la base con
jugada más estable el acetileno es el
compuesto más ácido de los tres y esto
también tiene un efecto en la electro
negatividad si un carbono con
hibridación esp atrae más a los
electrones recordemos la definición de
electro negatividad es la fuerza de un
átomo para atraer electrones hacia sí
mismo entonces como los electrones en un
carbono con hibridación s
y están más cerca del núcleo eso
significa que un carbono con hibridación
esp es más electro negativo que un
carbono con hibridación sp2 que a su vez
es más electro negativo que un carbono
con hibridación sp3 entonces la electro
negatividad tiene que ver con la
cantidad de orbital ese y esto puede ser
confuso porque siempre suponemos que el
carbono tiene un mismo valor de electro
negatividad pero ahora podemos ver que
es diferente un carbono con hibridación
esp es en realidad el más electro
negativo